so what about the Buddhist perspective
on things the meditative perspective
that I'm impermanent totally cool I'm
just going to you know enjoy the time
that I have rather than the rage against
work no no look I think I think the
philosophy of none of non-attachment
I'm not an expert on Buddhism my limited
understanding though has to do with not
holding on to things and embracing a
philosophy of non-attachment
as attachment is supposed to be bound to
the ego and if you transcend the ego and
you don't have attachment you suffer
less
yeah and my intuition is you suffer less
but you also feel less you love less you
desire less you agonize beautifully less
you express yourself intentionally less
interesting and so I think that the you
know the the art that moves me is the
art that arrests me is the art that
transform is the art that pains me is
the art that that gives me a nine
feeling in my stomach like III like the
push and pull the ecstasy and the agony
I think it's what makes us us I think
it's romantic
maybe I'm slightly masochistic but I I
am incompatible with the idea of
non-attachment you know when I look at
my family people that I love friendships
that I love places that I love like I
love those places and those people so
much it hurts right the music that I
love sometimes I listen to a song and I
love the song so much and I'll get sad
from just the thought that I don't have
eternity with which to listen to this
song for you know like I watch a film
like Inception and I'm just like oh my
god I just wished it that I could watch
this film like once a week for the next
million years you know like I just
there's just I get off
cognitively from from arts from ideas
and from beings that died that the whole
notion of just letting that go is
incongruent to me but to each his own
right can there can there be a feeling
of ecstasy with
with medicines with meditative feelings
as well of not attaching to that feeling
of ecstasy but you tell me I don't know
either
I've made a video of every insight I've
ever had because I didn't want to just
let it go if I would have get along on
attached to the I thought I was just
like you know meditation sometimes tells
us you know watch your thoughts but
don't you know don't be attached to them
certainly some thoughts are not useful
to attach yourself to but every video
that I made started with the thought
every video started with a thought I did
not let go of yes it was a thought I
became obsessed with I wanted to make
sense of it I wanted to tile it with
language share and and in making the
video was a kind of psychological
exorcism and it was only through the act
of making the video that I finally was
at peace and could let it go but see now
I haven't let it go now it's a thing
that exists forever in tangible form so
it's my battle against ephemerality my
all art is a battle against ephemerality
so I don't know I mean there's
non-attachment thing I don't get it I
think it's a way to placate ourselves
against the fear of death is what I
think it's a deathless rationalization
that in the face of no other choice
you know the may be the healthiest
response is to find some noble
acceptance like oh well it's God's will
for this person to die a horrific death
of cancer God's will you know it's what
God God wanted I just I don't buy it I
think it's a fricking tragedy I think
illness is a tragedy I think death is a
tragedy you know and we also don't know
what happens after death well hey I'm
sort of envious of people who are
convinced of an afterlife I'm envious
for their peace while they're alive but
I just you know I can't convince myself
doesn't mean that I can't be agnostic
but being agnostic doesn't doesn't rid
me of you know
the despair associated with infinite
nothing